comment vous dire c'est mon âge depuis
les 700 millions de Chinois de Jacques
Dutronc ont doublé ils sont 1 milliard 4
la population mondiale a également
doublée entre les années 70 et
aujourd'hui regardez cette courbe de
l'évolution 1 milliard en 1803 de
milliards 27 4 milliards dans les années
70-74 8 milliards en 2022 puisque l'ONU
nous l'a annoncé cette semaine et puis à
ses prévisions de monter jusqu'à 10
milliards autour des années 2080 on va
tout de suite voir le sujet qui nous
décrit cette frise chronologique avec
Samia de chia
le cap est franchi nous sommes désormais
8 milliards d'êtres humains un chiffre
qui donne le vertige si l'on regarde un
peu plus de 200 ans en arrière en 1800
nous n'étions encore qu'un petit
milliard puis la révolution industrielle
combinée au progrès de la médecine et de
l'hygiène vont provoquer une soudaine
accélération de la population mondiale
au 20e siècle
sommes-nous désormais trop nombreux pour
une seule planète
suffira-t-elle encore à nourrir tout le
monde pour cette démographie ce n'est
pas tant le nombre du monde qui importe
mais plutôt leur mode de vie pour
pouvoir nourrir les 8 milliards
d'humains donc il y a des études qui
montrent qu'à priori on serait en
capacité de le faire dans la mesure où
on change un petit peu nos modes de vie
mode de consommation la réduction par
exemple de
la consommation de viande notamment dans
les pays les plus riches d'après les
projections de l'ONU nous serons plus de
10 milliards d'êtres humains avant la
fin du siècle soit 2 milliard le plus
qu'aujourd'hui
jusqu'où la population mondiale
va-t-elle continuer d'augmenter en
réalité le rythme de croissance a déjà
commencé à ralentir la tendance
s'inverse sous l'effet de ce qu'on
appelle la transition démographique déjà
achevé en Occident elle touche désormais
presque tous les pays ce qui se passe
c'est que la plupart des pays du monde
sont passés d'un régime ou la mortalité
et la fécondité élevée à un autre régime
démographique qui est une mortalité plus
faible une espérance de vie qui augmente
et il fait quantité beaucoup plus basse
voire même comme je disais tout à
l'heure des pays qui descendent bien en
dessous de deux enfants par femme donc
jusqu'à un enfant par femme donc
actuellement en Corée du Sud autrement
dit les humains vivront plus longtemps
et feront moins d'enfants et c'est
peut-être là le vrai défi le
vieillissement de la population mondiale
d'ici 2050 le nombre de personnes de
plus de 65 ans va doubler dans le monde
soit un humain sur six contre un sur 10
aujourd'hui
et pour animer ce débat pour
nous éclairer je vous présente tout de
suite nos experts Emmanuel pour bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes ingénieur auteur du
livre faut-il arrêter de faire des
enfants pour sauver la planète publié
aux éditions Payot Marie féru bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes ingénieur en génie
urbain responsable de France de
l'association démographique responsable
Gilles Pizon bonsoir bienvenue à vous si
vous êtes professeur mérite au Muséum
National d'Histoire Naturelle conseiller
de la direction de la situation
nationale d'études démographique auteur
de l'Atlas de la population mondiale aux
éditions Autrement et puis on fera
référence aussi un article que vous avez
publié pour le média compte versation et
Mathieu croissanto évidemment est resté
à mes côtés merci Mathieu vous êtes
toujours éditorialiste politique ça n'a
pas changé entre la première et la
seconde partie Emmanuel pont ce qui
frappe on a vu la frise chronologique
tout à l'heure c'est
l'accélération du phénomène comment elle
s'explique cette moi ce que je peux
appeler une flambée démographique alors
c'est un petit peu particulier de dire
accélération du phénomène parce que
justement votre journaliste présenté à
raison le fait que ce taux de croissance
diminue de la population et cette elle
est plutôt partie pour se stabiliser
alors ce phénomène c'est l'accélération
on a le sentiment contre les années 70
et aujourd'hui c'est à ce moment-là
qu'il y a une accélération plus forte au
contraire ça ralent encore depuis les
années 70 le pic de croissance de la
population mondiale il était justement
autour de des années de Jacques Dutronc
dans les années 65-70 et donc ce
phénomène c'est ce qu'on appelle la
transition démographique la transition
démographique c'est ce moment où quand
la mortalité baisse dans des pays grâce
au projet au progrès de l'hygiène de
l'alimentation de la santé etc la
natalité baisse avec du retard et donc
ce retard fait que pendant cette période
transitoire la population augmente et
donc ça c'est quelque chose sur lequel
passe par lequel passe tous les pays par
exemple la France a mis 150 à 200 ans à
faire sa transition démographique ça a
été très progressif le reste du monde et
en particulier ce qu'on appelait à cette
époque là le tiers-monde était en train
de faire sa transition démographique à
ce moment-là d'où cette croissance
aujourd'hui la plupart de ces pays l'ont
fini aujourd'hui à peu près 70% de la
population mondiale et dans des pays
au-dessous de deux enfants par femme
gipison ça veut dire que la population
mondiale elle double à peu près au même
rythme depuis les années 20 c'est ça
depuis un siècle alors justement non
27 4 milliards en 74 ça fait 50 ans à
peu près on rajoute 50 ans on est on est
dans les années 2022 on a encore doublé
alors il faut peut-être se baser sur le
taux de croissance annuelle et comme ça
vient d'être dit par Emmanuel pont le
taux de croissance annuel de la
population mondiale est passé par un
maximum il y a 60 ans dans les années
1960 et à l'époque il a atteint ce
maximum de plus de 2% par an et depuis
il n'a cessé de diminuer alors la
situation a continué d'augmenter mais un
rythme qui a dit sur le chiffre total et
depuis 60 ans Alors c'est intéressant et
dans leur projets les démographes
notamment des Nations Unies font
l'hypothèse que cette diminution du taux
de croissance démographique va se
poursuivre et amènerait la population
mondiale à la croissance 0 dans la
décennie 2080 et elle diminuerait
ensuite donc on atteindrait un maximum
de un peu plus de 10 milliards
d'habitants dans le scénario moyen des
Nations Unies et ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que on était un milliard vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre sujet en 1800
on devrait être autour de 10 milliards
en 2100 la population mondiale aura
décuplé en trois siècles donc c'est unir
ça n'était jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
des humains et ça n'arrivera sans doute
jamais aujourd'hui on est en fin de
cette période de croissance très
importante 8 milliards il reste un
surcroît de 2 milliards en plus par
rapport à 8 milliard donc un quart en
plus après une multiplication par 8 des
humains donc vous voyez que le gros de
la croissance démographique mondiale
bien compris et derrière nous et devant
nous il y a un reliquat de croissance et
on entrevoit la croissance démographique
0 avant la fin du siècle je vais vous
donner la parole dans un cours instant
Mathieu vous lui intervenir l'âge moyen
de l'être humain sur terre et ce qu'il
s'élève avec le temps oui et parce que
on vit de plus en plus longtemps et
alors un indicateur qui est proche c'est
l'âge médian donc c'est l'âge qui divise
la population mondiale en deux parties
égales et aujourd'hui il est de 31 ans
donc si vous avez 31 ans la moitié de
l'humanité est plus jeune que vous
l'autre moitié est plus âgé dans un pays
comme la France on est nettement
au-dessus 44 ans le chiffre le plus
élevé c'est le Japon du pays qui à la
population la plus vieille
démographiquement avec 48 ou 49 ans
d'âge médian donc l'âge moyen augmente
et pourquoi parce que on vit de plus en
plus longtemps et on fait de moins en
moins d'enfants donc les naissants
diminuent c'est un phénomène qui a
commencé il y a deux siècles dans les
pays qui ont connu la transition
démographique en Europe l'année du Nord
et qui se poursuit dans ces pays-là et
qui s'est étendu partout sur la planète
donc la population mondiale vieillit
partout c'est un des grands défis dont
on parle peut-être pas assez parce que
là on parle du nombre total d'êtres
humains mais les 10 milliards de demain
la répartition par âge sera différente
de celle d'aujourd'hui alors 10
milliards d'êtres humains d'êtres
humains en 2080 autour de de cette de
cette date la planète peut-elle
supporter autant d'êtres humains c'est
ça rejoint la thèse et l'association
démographique responsable vous répondez
non c'est ça
8 milliards c'est pas soutenable pour la
planète et on aurait dû s'occuper de ce
problème depuis déjà les années 70 quand
on a commencé à prendre des milliards
tous les 15 15 ans 12 ans de plus en de
manière de plus en plus rapprochée même
si c'est vrai que le taux de fécondité
au global diminue je veux dire les
milliards continuent d'augmenter et
c'est ça qui compte donc la planète
n'est pas extensible avec le nombre des
humains donc ce problème doit être
traité au niveau international comme on
traite du réchauffement climatique et
des problèmes planétaires hors ce point
est un sujet très tabou on n'a pas le
droit d'en discuter on n'a pas le droit
de le mettre sur la table et de dire
qu'il faut s'en occuper et aider les
femmes à avoir la contraception pour et
encourager les femmes conscientiser les
femmes sur l'urgence climatique sur
l'état de la planète pour qu'au plus
vite mais le plus vite possible on ne
fasse plus que un ou deux enfants par
femme qu'on continue pas à faire comme
si de rien n'était comme tout va bien
voilà l'état de la planète on s'en fiche
du moment que tout le monde a la liberté
tout le monde a la liberté de Mathieu et
pas faux qu'est-ce qui se passe pour
ceux qui en font plus et puis comment on
fait dans par exemple sur le continent
africain qui est aujourd'hui je ne pense
pas me tromper et celui où là où la
natalité
des femmes
toutes les internationale ça devrait
être principalement de la contraception
et surtout conscientiser puisque les
jeunes femmes en France
des 18-25 ans ou 30 ans sont de plus en
plus conscientes de de la problème de
surpopulation et sont prêtes à se
sacrifier à ne pas avoir d'enfants pour
sauver la planète alors que en fait il
faudrait que cette conscience là arrive
à toutes les femmes du monde et même les
hommes puisque on fait toujours que
c'est les femmes qui font les enfants
mais enfin c'est les hommes qui sont
inconscients souvent ou qui poussent les
femmes à avoir des enfants de manière à
contrôler toutes les religions donc ce
point doit absolument
être pris en compte au plus vite quoi
c'est une urgence vitale alors qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez l'un et l'autre je
commence avec vous Emmanuel point un pro
une sorte de programme mondial
internationale centrée sur cette
question je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur tout ça alors déjà
parler de problèmes de la population de
dire qu'il aurait fallu sans occuper
c'est particulier parce que la
population c'est des gens c'est des
êtres humains on le rappelle et il
aurait fallu s'en occuper dans les
années 70 on vient d'en parler justement
les années 70 c'est bien c'était ce
moment où la majorité du monde faisait
sa transition démographique et donc dans
ces années là les pays les plus riches
du monde eux avaient déjà une natalité
qui avait baissé et les autres et qui
étaient des pays très pauvres en
majorité à l'époque avait une natalité
élevée alors je pense que ça aurait été
très bien qu'il se développe à ce
moment-là mais ce processus de
transition démographique c'est quelque
chose qui est lent qui est lié à on l'a
vu la France par exemple 150 ans c'est
lié à des changements culturels des
changements économiques c'est pas
quelque chose sur lequel
[Musique]
une simulation puisque vous avez un
programme super où on peut simuler
l'avenir de la planète en fonction de
l'espérance de vie du nombre d'enfants
par femme différents paramètres et donc
je me suis amusée à faire une simulation
ou si on ne faisait qu'un seul enfant
par femme à partir d'aujourd'hui à
partir d'aujourd'hui et bien je suis
arrivé que on arrivait à diminuer de
moitié la population repasser à 4
milliards en 65 ans seulement avec grâce
à votre logiciel donc ça peut être très
rapide
va s'occuper de dire aux femmes et de
vérifier que elles vont avoir un enfant
chacune tout de suite
trois enfants en moyenne chacune à
l'échelle mondiale à l'échelle mondiale
c'était plus du double cinq enfants il y
a 50 ans et la fécondité mondiale
moyenne
ne cesse de diminuer parce que les
femmes les couples ont fait le choix
partout
d'avoir peu d'enfants pour le rassurer
une vie de qualité et longue mais tout
sauf en Afrique quand même il tendit
un résultat il n'en résulte pas tout de
suite un arrêt de la croissance
démographique prenez le cas de l'Inde
qui va devenir le premier pays par la
population dans un ou deux ans voilà 1,4
milliards d'Indiens et bien vous savez
que la fécondité des femmes en Inde et
de 2,0 enfants par femme elle est en
dessous du seuil de remplacement des
générations qui permet mais il ne
résulte pas un arrêt de la croissance
démographique de l'Inde l'un dans les
projections démographiques va continuer
d'augmenter en termes de population pour
atteindre 1,7 milliards d'habitants au
milieu du siècle et ensuite se mettre à
diminuer pourquoi la population indienne
continue-t-elle d'augmenter alors que
les femmes et les couples ont moins
d'enfants que ce qu'il faut pour le
remplacement des générations c'est parce
que la population indienne est jeune
démographiquement elle comprend une
proportion importante de jeunes adultes
en âge d'avoir des enfants même si
chacun d'eux dès maintenant on peut
d’enfants deux enfants
et bien ça fait plus de naissance
beaucoup de naissances parce qu'ils sont
nombreux c'est pas le fait qu'elle a
fait qu'on était soit élevée par
ailleurs la population indienne est
jeune démographiquement elle comprend
une proportion faible de personnes âgées
ou très âgées or en Inde comme presque
partout dans le monde maintenant les
décès surviennent aux âges élevés voire
très élevés donc ça fait peu de décès et
donc la démonstration c'est ce que les
démographes appellent l'inertie
démographique même si aujourd'hui un
enfant est né par femme tout de suite
partout
regardez
je sais pas comment on y arrive mais bon
c'est complètement fictif
la population continue d'augmenter
encore jusqu'en 2050 mais oui je l'ai
conçu ce logiciel que je vous le
recommande et vous avez raison de
l'utiliser mais ça veut dire que il y a
une inertie démographique donc il faut
tenir compte et sinon si vous voulez que
la population mondiale s'arrête de
croire de voir 10 minutes tout de suite
il faut augmenter la mortalité où il
faut envoyer une partie de l'humanité
sur Mars bon alors vous allez pouvoir
répondre mais Mathieu a une question
madame votre raisonnement il a il
s'appuie sur un raisonnement
mathématique mais votre propos il a une
portée politique qui peut être jugé
rassurant pour les gens qui veulent qui
moi d'habitants sur terre ou inquiétante
pour les gens qui se sont attachés les
libertés individuelles de choisir le
destin familial et de faire autant
d'enfants qui veulent comment au-delà de
l'éducation comment vous dans votre dans
la portée de votre propos que ça se
traduit comment concrètement on interdit
aux gens de faire des enfants on
contrôle on incite et on conscientise
vous savez les femmes de la française
dystopie
ça a été tenté dans un pays et on peut
en parler un sondage Ifop au mois
d'octobre un sondage sérieux il faut un
par Monsieur Jérôme Fourquet
pensez-vous que auprès de d'un
échantillon de français pensez-vous que
la planète est surpeuplée oui à 72 %, il
y a une conscience
à propos des atteintes à l'environnement
diriez-vous que la croissance
démographique mondiale a joué un rôle
important oui à 66% l'aide
internationale doit être axée sur la
contraception à l'éducation des jeunes
dans ces pays envoie développement oui à
58%
concernant même la population française
pensez-vous que nous devrions plutôt
chercher à la stabiliser et même à la
réduire oui à 65%, les gens sont tout à
fait conscients contrairement à ce qu'on
entend les
la question en Asie ou en Afrique
pas la question je veux dire il y a
d'autres sondages sur le désir d'enfant
en c'est en France comme globalement
dans les pays riches les gens ont moins
d'enfants qui ne souhaitent en France
c'est à peu près 30% des gens qui à la
fin de leur vie reproductive ont eu
moins d'enfants que ce qu'ils auraient
aimé donc dire il y a qu'à convaincre
ces gens d'avoir beaucoup moins
d'enfants alors qu'aujourd'hui ils en
veulent plus c'est particulier
d'autant plus que population il faut pas
croire que non ils sont conscients du
problème écologique
on va revenir sur le désir d'enfant ou
pas avec avec
le lien entre entre
la population mondiale actuelle et
les dérèglements climatiques est-ce
qu'il faut faire moi d'enfants pour
soulager la planète en quelque sorte
parce que c'est forcément un facteur
mais en même temps dans ces 8 milliards
et ben on compte pour un indien
d'Amazonie et le milliardaire américain
et toute la myriade de vie de société
d'organisation qui vont derrière et donc
on voit bien que à moins d'être prêt à
agir très violemment
sur la natalité parce que bah réduire un
enfant par femme en fait c'est l'enfant
unique mais c'est l'enfant unique dur en
Chine Nicolas c'était entre 1,5 et 2,5
fois par femme pour réduire la plupart
des abus et encore il y en a eu un
certain nombre de concurrent des
stérilisations forcées de tout ce qui
est la plus passée donc ce un enfant par
femme aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose de
pour dire tyrannique donc
cette population on se rend compte qu'en
fait à moins d'être très contraignant on
a peu de chances de la faire bouger on
la fera bouger contre les avis des gens
et à côté de ça on a des modes de vie
qui eux ont des différences qui vont de
1 à 10 à 100 à 1000 et donc forcément la
population est un facteur mais est-ce
que c'est un bon levier et est-ce que
c'est le facteur principal par rapport à
d'autres choses c'est beaucoup plus
douteux alors je vous donne la parole
dans un instant mais je voudrais que tu
es un traduit nous rejoigne tout de
suite
rebons soient artham pour parler
effectivement de ces personnes qui ne
qui ne veulent plus d'enfants il y a
plusieurs études plusieurs sondages
récents qui reviennent et oui vous en
avez parlé il y a eu un sondage de
l'Ifop un récemment réalisé avec le
magazine Elle sortie fin septembre et
qui a abouti à la conclusion que près
d'un tiers des femmes en âge de procrées
30 % précisément ne veulent pas
d'enfants un sondage qui fait écho à une
autre étude une étude américaine menée
dans le Michigan par l'Université du
Michigan qui montrait qu'un quart des
jeunes adultes interrogés ne voulaient
pas avoir d'enfants une tendance à la
hausse puisque lors des enquêtes
précédentes le taux des jeunes adultes
ne voulant pas d'enfants aussi là entre
deux et 9% c'était du déclaratif c'était
ne voulait pas avoir d'enfant ça veut
pas dire qu'ils n'allaient pas du tout
en avoir mais on observe aussi une
baisse de la fécondité en France chez
les 20-29 ans et là encore attention à
ne pas en tirer des conclusions trop
hâtives et définitive cela peut aussi
refléter un recul de l'âge d'entrée dans
la parentalité le fait que l'on ait des
enfants de plus en plus alors chez ces
jeunes qui disent ne pas vouloir
d'enfants il y a il y a le lien avec la
volonté de préserver la planète parfois
et oui il y a parfois ce lien ce sont
même des mouvements vraiment structurés
dans le monde anglo-saxon les gings pour
green inclination no kids qui veut dire
engagement envers pas d'enfants dont
l'une des figures de proue et laylani
Münter x championnat automobile
aujourd'hui
âgé de 45 ans à la décider de ne pas
avoir d'enfants pour des raisons
environnementales écouter là dans une
vidéo qui a été tournée pour
l'association population matters ONG
britannique qui fait la promotion d'une
vie sans enfant
une position qui va elle dans le sens
d'une étude qui a été menée par des
chercheurs en Suède en 2017 et qui a
identifié quatre mesures individuelles
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ces quatre mesures c'est
d'abord devenir végétarien éviter de
voyager en avion on en a beaucoup parlé
ne pas avoir de voiture et enfin faire
moins d'enfants car cela permettrait
selon cette étude d'économiser 58 tonnes
d'émissions de CO2 par an je ne sais pas
comment ils sont arrivés à ce chiffre
évidemment ça dépend aussi forcément de
son mode de vie il y a pas que des
raisons environnementales derrière ces
personnes qui disent ne pas vouloir non
il n'y a pas que les anxiété les
motivations elles sont complexes elles
sont variées il y a la période de crise
d'austérité de précarisation de la
jeunesse que nous connaissons puis il y
a aussi et bien la liberté de chacun il
y a les choix de carrière le refus du
sacerdoce que peut représenter un enfant
bref il y a des raisons intimes un choix
aussi personnel qu'avoir un enfant que
de ne pas en avoir en tout cas pour ceux
qui n'en veulent pas il y a une bonne
nouvelle puisque on a appris mardi la
baisse mondiale de la fertilité
masculine le nombre de spermatozoïdes
décroît dans le monde cela peut donc
devenir un danger pour l'humanité dise
certains médecins les Gims vous diront
eux peut-être que c'est au contraire à
la solution pour sauver notre planète
merci Tom pour pour ces infos on
reviendra sur le chiffre des 58 tonnes
d'émissions de CO2 parce que il peut
être sujet à caution je voudrais vous
entendre Gilles Pison sur effectivement
cette dernière information la baisse
mondiale de la fertilité masculine
est-ce que ça alors j'ai bien compris on
était dans des processus qui était lents
mais est-ce que ça peut
inverser la tendance qui est donnée on
va passer du 8 milliards aujourd'hui à
10 milliards d'ici 50 ans
non non parce que là vous parlez de la
capacité de concevoir un enfant alors
c'est vrai que ça dépend de la qualité
du sperme masculin parce que la baisse
de la fertilité elle est avérée chez les
hommes elle a baissé le moitié dans les
pays avancés pour des raisons sans doute
d'environnement de présence de produits
chimiques en l'air et tout alors ça
n'empêche pas les couples qui souhaitent
avoir un enfant
dans concevoir simplement ça allonge le
délai de conception qui est déjà long
nous sommes nous Homo sapiens une espèce
peu fertile c'est pas très facile de
concevoir un enfant la probabilité de
concevoir au cours d'un seul cycle quand
la femme a enlevé son stérilet ou ne
prend plus la pilule elle est de 1/4
seulement
et donc il y a ce délai de 5 6 mois chez
des couples normalement fertiles et le
fait que la fertilité masculine est
baissée ça allait le délai mais au total
les couples qui veulent avoir un enfant
et ben ils y arrivent c'est un petit peu
plus long et si vous voulez c'est pas ça
le facteur le facteur important c'est le
souhait des femmes des hommes des
couples d'avoir ou non un enfant c'était
votre sujet et la plupart arrive à avoir
l'enfant qui souhaite ceux qui n'en
souhaitent pas et c'était votre sujet il
y a plein de raisons les enfants ça
coûte c'est fatigant c'est des
contraintes pour la vie il faut prévenir
c'est du boudin aussi beaucoup de
bonheur ceux qui n'en souhaite pas qu'il
n'en est pas mais la majorité des des
hommes des femmes notamment chez les
jeunes souhaitent avoir un enfant un
jour et moi je leur dis bah
il est très minoritaire ultra en France
et puis
vous en voulez je leur dis si vous en
voulez ayez-en et le nombre que vous
souhaitez mais arrangez-vous pour les
éduquer de façon à ce que ils aient un
mode de vie responsable et durable quand
ils seront adultes à 20-25 ans que leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre net
soit nul la question
importante pour le futur et notamment
pour ce défi du réchauffement climatique
ce n'est pas le nombre des humains c'est
les modes de vie pourquoi parce que on
ne agira pas à court terme sur la courbe
démographique on échappera pas à se
surcroît de 2 milliards d'humains en
revanche on peut agir sur le mode de vie
on doit agir pour les rendre plus
respectueux de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité et il y a pas si vous
voulez de plan B c'est le levier sur
lequel on peut agir bien sûr la baisse
de la fécondité qui est engagée et qui
se poursuit va
produire un arrêt de la croissance
démographique mais ça va prendre des
décennies et là on a que quelques années
quelques décennies pour changer le cours
j'ai bien compris du réchauffement
pardon je voudrais vous entendre sur ce
ce chiffre entre nu et le mettait un
pays pas mal de bémol la 58 tonnes
d'émission de CO2 par an et juste avant
je voulais revenir sur le sondage d'elle
sur les 30% de femmes qui renoncent
avoir des enfants c'est des femmes qui
n'ont pas d'enfants si on compte sur
l'ensemble des femmes sur les mêmes
chiffres ils sont à 13% ce qui est déjà
plus que les sondages précédents qui
tournaient autour de 5% et qui était
plutôt stable mais qui sont pas
forcément comparables pour des raisons
de méthodologie donc c'est déjà un
chiffre plus faible et pareil l'étude
d'université du Michigan c'est les gens
qui n'ont pas de désir d'enfant à
l'instant T c'est pas forcément les gens
qui renoncent aux enfants donc là encore
on rentre dans tous les états
de cette mesure et alors c'est 58 alors
gigantesque
l'empreinte carbone du Français moyen
c'est 10 tonnes comment est-ce qu'on
arrive à faire l'empreinte de 6
personnes avec un enfant d'autant plus
que quand on regarde le calcul c'est
plutôt 12 parce que c'est divisé par an
et ben en fait c'est un calcul
extrêmement théorique de toutes les
émissions futures de votre descendance
future et hypothétique jusqu'à la fin
des temps c'est à dire que 7 ans on
rajoute les enfants de cet enfance voilà
les enfants de 7 enfants les enfants
suivants divisent par deux à chaque
génération et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
arrive à ce chiffre gigantesque qui en
fait ne nous dit absolument rien parce
que Ben mes arrières arrières petits
enfants hypothétiques ben on sait pas
s'ils existent on sait pas leurs
émissions et leurs émissions futures et
contribuent pas au réchauffement
climatique aujourd'hui donc c'est
quelque chose qui a vraiment rien à voir
et qui en plus je trouve
philosophiquement et embêtant c'est à
dire qu'avoir un enfant c'est pas un
choix de consommation comme comme
prendre l'avion ou manger de la viande
c'est un peu perturbant dans la liste la
devise de ne pas avoir de voiture
responsabilité puis il y a des questions
on n'est pas que des consommateurs il y
a une question aussi de société dans
lesquels on vit
faire est-ce que faire un enfant ça
entérine les émissions qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans un certain cadre bon
tout ça c'est problématique moi je
l'avais proposé un contre calcul si une
famille écolo à un enfant et que donc
les enfants ils consomment peu en fait
si elle réduit ses émissions au rythme
qui à peu près celui de l'accord de
Paris
qu'aujourd'hui la moyenne de la société
n'atteint pas mais qui est pas forcément
si loin que ça quand on est prêt à faire
un peu d'efforts qui sont pas forcément
abominable et ben on arrive autour d'une
tonne par an alors c'est pas 0 mais
c'est pas 50 ans de grandeur bien sûr
Maria Perru vous pourriez insister
là-dessus sur le mode de vie plutôt que
sur le le nombre d'enfants oui mais
justement on ne parle que de la
consommation c'est vrai faut modifier
complètement notre consommation et
principalement ne plus émettre de gaz à
effet de serre ou le minimum possible
nous sommes d'accord mais ça va pas être
suffisant parce que là on ne parle
quasiment que de vécu du changement
climatique mais les limites planétaires
il y a sur il y a 9 limites planétaires
d'après les scientifiques dont 6 sont
déjà franchis on est au-delà de ce que
fournir la planète donc alors il y a le
réchauffement climatique il y a
l'érosion de la biodiversité avec
l'extinction massive des espèces
animales et de biodiversité on a
perturbé le site le cycle de l'azote et
du phosphore donc avec les sols qui sont
appauvris l'agriculture intensive
c'est un peu fastidieux de des limites
planétaires mais donc vous dites comme
on a déjà dépassé les limites
planétaires dans un certain nombre de
cas il faut il faut le seul moyen de
d'être étudiant c'est de faire moins
d'enfant il faut utiliser non faut
utiliser tout ce qui est à notre
disposition pour ne plus être en
dépassement partout donc faut jouer et
sur la consommation et sur le nombre
faut jouer sur les deux parce que si on
ne joue que sur la consommation il y a
des milliards on cons moins et puis il y
a deux trois milliards qui arrivent en
plus mais ils vont consommer on va pas
leur dire vous arrivez on va pas nier au
pays en voie de développement le droit
on va panier au pays en voie de l'épaule
de développement le droit à la
croissance quoi c'est une croissance
c'est assez simple hein développement il
faut qu'il y ait moins de monde sinon il
y aura pas de croissance c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible peut-être
une réponse rapide vous rêvez d'une
planète peupleée et tout de suite
supposer je sais pas comment que on soit
qu'un milliard sur la planète tout de
suite mais que ce milliard
et le mode de vie des Américains des
Européens d'aujourd'hui donc ils
continuent comme si de rien n'était mais
on va dans le mur ça ne va pas le but
c'est on voit bien que ce milliard cette
minorité de 1 milliard est la ses
activités ont été responsables du
réchauffement climatique jusqu'ici et
eux
qui ont émis
[Musique]
et donc le défi c'est que au nord nous
nous réduisions et tout de suite et
drastiquement nos émissions de Gazette
et de serre et puis que au sud et bien
ils ont légitimement
aspiration à vivre mieux mais qu'ils
vivent mieux
en ne suivant pas la trajectoire que
l'on a suivi et on ne copions pas les
modes de vie non durable des pays du
Nord et de changer nos modes de vie au
nord puisque nous sommes copiés dans nos
bottes de vie sort un effet bien sûr sur
nos émissions locales mais aussi dans le
sud puisque quand on y sera arrivé on
nos bottes de vie vont être copiés et
donc l'important c'est pas tellement le
nombre des humains on voit bien que la
croissance démographique mondiale elle
est en train de se terminer et que il y
a un reliquat de croissance tout ce qui
est modeste mais ça va prendre un peu de
temps en raison de l'inertie
démographique et on n'a pas le choix il
faut modifier nos modes de vie
rapidement et tout de suite et sinon on
peut rêver à des solutions des
catastrophes
un astéroïde géant de la taille de celui
qui est tombé il y a 66 millions
d'années au Mexique qui a contribué à la
cinquième extinction massive d'espèces
dont la disparition des dinosaures donc
c'est peut-être un peu ce genre de
scénario que vous avez en tête mais il
est très peu probable et le plus
probable c'est que on va être un peu
plus nombreux mais il va falloir faire
avec on peut non je vous redonne
donc nous on veut retomber à trois
quatre milliards pas plus mais pas plus
regardez sur votre site de Lynette
pardon et puis en plus vous nous dites
que
Ford de nos consommations effectivement
nous
occidentaux pays riches depuis un siècle
et plus mettons la planète dans cet état
là on va maintenant imposer au pays en
voie de développement d'arrêter de faire
des enfants c'est quand même gonflé nous
on s'impose de ne plus les mettre de gaz
à effet de serre de ne plus avoir de
qualité donc et de ne plus croître en
population nous aussi même en France
même en France on devrait être avec nos
ce qu'il y a en renouvelable sur la
France on devrait être que la moitié 35
millions et dans votre équation vous
oubliez quand même le les pays en
question qui peut-être vont vous rire au
nez en venant de Madame pardon mais
posez-vous la question de la
responsabilité de votre conseiller
d'avoir des guerres épouvantables qui
aura passé d'eau pour tout le monde avec
une sécheresse épouvantable
où il y aura plus on pourra plus faire
pousser les plantes les forêts vont tout
brûler vous croyez que c'est une vie
vivable alors Emmanuel ponce
catastrophisme
vous vous le repoussez dans votre lit
vous faites la démonstration alors je
pense qu'à la fois il faut bien être
conscient des risques parce que oui on a
des risques de catastrophe qui peuvent
arriver et qui ne sont pas écrits parce
que ça va dépendre de ce que choisit
l'humanité aujourd'hui et autant on peut
être inquiet de cette trajectoire et on
peut avoir aussi un peu d'espoir vers
certaines choses qui vont mieux pas
toutes soyons clairs le juste milieu et
pas forcément au milieu là-dessus après
on peut justement regarder ses limites
planétaires et se dire la même chose
est-ce que avec une mesure absolument
abominable
contraintes les gens on divise la
population par deux en 2100 donc
reprenons cette expérience de pensée et
on peut regarder ce qu'on peut faire à
côté donc par exemple à côté on se rend
compte que beaucoup des sujets
écologiques sont des sujets
d'agriculture donc que ça soit la
biodiversité parce que c'est
l'occupation des sols aujourd'hui 99%
des sols de l'humanité qui sont occupés
par l'agriculture l'occupation l'eau la
dégradation des cycles de nutriments la
déforestation etc il y a beaucoup de
leviers pour nourrir les gens parce que
ça serait une question et pour avoir une
agriculture soutenable par exemple une
vraie question c'est on peut être 10
milliards on a dans dans 30 ou 40 ans
en changeant de modèle c'est à dire
alors on a déjà de quoi nourrir
largement tout le monde mais aujourd'hui
il y a des gens qui meurent de faim
parce que c'est plus rentable de vendre
des céréales des élevages en Europe que
de les vendre à des gens pauvres en
Afrique et on pourrait tout à fait donc
il y a eu un certain nombre d'études là
dessus notamment Agrimonde de l'INRA du
Cirad en France sur comment nourrir 10
milliards de personnes et là-dessus on a
des grands leviers d'action qui sont le
gaspillage on gaspiller à peu près un
tiers de notre nourriture la viande
alors la viande c'est vraiment le gros
sujet si l'humanité devenait
végétarienne demain on libérerait trois
quarts des terres utilisées trois quarts
ça vous donne une idée de la de la
puissance de se lever d'action par
rapport à la démographie ce qui veut pas
dire qu'on doit 100% devenir végétarien
leader que ces terres très peu utilisé
d'une autre manière mais ça montre que
bah il y a des choses qui peuvent être
faites relativement vite et qui elle
agiront sur toute sur tous les sujets
écologiques et sans avoir parce qu'on en
a pas parlé des faits rebonds
c'est-à-dire que si on est deux fois
moins est-ce qu'on va polluer deux fois
moins
très vaste question est-ce que si on est
deux fois oui c'est quoi c'est qu'on se
dise continue ah bah bien sûr est-ce que
alors il y a déjà ce risque politique
est-ce que ce qu'on fait pas aujourd'hui
on le fera si on est moins est-ce que si
on est deux fois moins en fermera la
moitié des puits de pétrole est-ce que
si on est deux fois moins la culture
consumériste va disparaître est-ce que
si on est deux fois moins les pays
riches suivront leurs engagements et ce
qu'ils arrêteront de repousser les
risques sur les pays pauvres non en fait
si on est deux fois moins tous les
grands déterminants et qui sont
justement un peu plus larges que cette
question des modes de vie mais qui sont
des mécanismes politiques économique et
culturelles tous ces grands déterminants
il reste là alors c'est un je vais vous
redonner la parole tout de suite c'est
un peu ce que ce que disait le
secrétaire général de l'ONU c'est une
phrase très courte vous allez voir il la
prononce à l'occasion de la Coop 27 en
Égypte Antonio Guterres
dirons-nous quand ce 8 milliardième bébé
sera en âge de nous demander
qu'avez-vous fait pour notre monde et
pour notre planète quand vous en aviez
l'occasion
il est là le vrai levier il est dans mon
comportement mais ça sera insuffisant si
alors vous dites qu'il faut pas de
contraintes il faut pas contraindre les
gens à encourager à faire moins
d'enfants par contre au niveau des
contraintes ne plus manger de viande ne
plus prendre l'avion ne plus utiliser la
voiture ne plus chauffer un nombre de
contraintes immenses alors tout
d'utiliser deux fois moins en plus on
aura plus d'énergie très prochainement
puisque on aura plus de pétrole
puisqu'il y a plus de charbon on aura
peut-être quelques centrales nucléaires
qui vont rester mais enfin ce sera
insuffisant pour avoir autant d'énergie
que ce qu'on a actuellement donc on sera
incapable de d'avoir tout le confort
qu'on a maintenant ça va être très
difficile il y a des il y a des
scénarios qui ont été définis par RTE et
qui est qui nous prouve que on peut tout
à fait ça prendra du temps mais
remplacer les énergies fossiles par un
mix par exemple énergie renouvelable et
nucléaire donc vous dressez un tableau
qui est le plus noir possible
je parle là je parle pas de la France
donc si vous voulez qu'en Afrique il se
développe en Asie etc que tout le monde
essaie centrales nucléaire déjà il y
aura pas assez d'uranium pour tout le
monde donc il faut trouver d'autres
formes d'énergie pour l'instant on est
un peu à court donc c'est pas avec trois
panneaux solaires dans un coin qu'on
aura le même la même énergie qu'on a
actuellement quoi
je pense c'est un excellent exemple
parce que entre l'énergie qui est
utilisée par l'Américain moyen et celle
utilisée par l'Afrique un moyen et ben
on a de à 100 ou de 1 à 1000 donc on
voit que le besoin en énergie il dépend
moins de du nombre de gens que de la
manière dont ils vivent
bon la question des modes de vie c'est
cruciale et il faut pas oublier que on
doit réduire les inégalités parce qu'on
voit bien que les comportements sont pas
les mêmes et les consommations de
ressources non plus et si on est 10
milliards ce qui est très probable dans
quelques décennies mais pas plus pas des
dizaines il faut aussi qu'on réduise les
inégalités entre pays et à l'intérieur
des pays or pour l'instant
la plupart des pays en développement
comme on les appelait qui se développent
et bien ça se traduit par une montée des
inégalités donc un des défis et bien ça
sera d'être plus nombreux de nourrir et
on a on en a parlé c'est possible c'est
10 milliards mieux que on ne nourrit les
lumières mais il faut changer nos
agriculture et en réduisant les
inégalités qui sont en train de monter à
l'intérieur des pays émergents et donc
il y a des défis mais
la courbe démographique on va pas la
modifier à court terme il faut faire
avec vous nous parliez de l'Inde tout à
l'heure et vous et vous l'évoquez
évidemment cet article que vous avez
signé pour le média conversation de
coversation l'Inde un bon qui va donc
devenir le premier pays peuplé au monde
avec notamment ses
mégalopoles dans lesquels les conditions
de vie sont déjà désastreuses écoutez ce
que Scandi la directrice d'une fondation
indienne sur la population
[Musique]
les gens vivent dans des conditions de
surpopulation avec très peu d'espace et
aucune infrastructure il y a un manque
d'accès flagrant à l'éducation à la
santé ce qui engendre une nouvelle
génération de personnes en mauvaise
santé ils ne sont pas seulement malade
mais aussi analphabètes et incapable de
participer à l'économie du pays à cause
de leur manque de qualification le coût
des opportunités est élevé
Emmanuel point est-ce que les humains
sont condamnés à s'agglutiner dans des
villes de plus en plus gigantesque moi
je vous avoue je suis toujours très
embêté par ce débat sur les villes parce
que est-ce que si ces gens vivaient à la
campagne ils vivaient mieux
s'ils ont choisi d'aller vers les villes
ils ont choisi d'aller en ville c'est
pas pour rien au passage ils ont
beaucoup moins d'enfants en Inde la
natalité dans les villes ça peut près
1,6 enfants par femme et 2,3 dans les
campagnes donc les logiques changent et
on se fait que c'est une réalité bien
sûr
population qui sont pas adaptées
forcément quand on est dans une ville on
est plus dans une situation où les gens
sont plus proches mais les grandes
villes savaient pas dire des qualités de
vie dégradées au contraire si les ruraux
vont en ville s'il y a cet exode rural
et il date pas de avant-hier ça fait
depuis très longtemps c'est parce que on
y trouve les services les métiers les
emplois et tout et c'est qu'on vit mieux
que dans les campagnes alors vous
redonne la parole mégalopole ça veut pas
forcément dire mégapollution parce que
c'est
variable en fait alors déjà on a
beaucoup de on a beaucoup de fantasmes
sur les bidons villes en Inde qui par
certains points de vue sont peuvent être
sales dans etc et qui part d'autres sont
des milieux extrêmement riches
extrêmement efficaces on avait vu par
exemple parce que on avait des bidons
villes en Inde qui avait des politiques
covid dont on pourrait s'inspirer l'État
français
et donc après ça dépend de comment les
villes sont faites et il se trouve que
les villes ont cette avantage écologique
de pouvoir être extrêmement efficace
pour beaucoup de choses mais ça dépend
c'est pas la vie américaine qui est
extrêmement étalée et qui demande
constamment des voitures par contre la
ville européenne la ville asiatique
permet d'avoir des niveaux de vie
relativement élevés avec des des
pollutions qui sont bien plus réduites
que pour un niveau de vie équivalent à
la campagne merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vais
rappeler le titre de votre livret manel
pont faut-il arrêter de faire des
enfants pour sauver la planète on est
aux éditions Payot Gilles pigeon de la
classe de la population mondiale chez
autrement et puis votre article pour le
média the converse station merci encore
je vous dis à lundi merci pour votre
fidélité demain matin bonjour chez vous
Oriane Mancini reçoit l'académicien Éric
Orsenna ils vont continuer de parler de
l'État notre planète notamment
l'histoire de nos fleuves et de nos
ressources en eau belle soirée
[Musique]